[MUSIC]
Welcome back.
We've been looking at how frameworks
help developers become more productive.
And we've taken a deep dive into
specific features of backbone and
underscore.
In this lesson, you'll be using
the Angular framework to put together
a simple app that let's you record menu
items for a specific meal of the day.
We'll be diving into Angular
version one, which is a mature and
stable framework.
Angular two is currently
under development and
is not backwards compatible
with Angular one.
Just as a local model is built up of
a number of different pieces to form
a complete design.
Frameworks are built up of
different techniques and concepts.
Learning the concepts and this lesson
will make it easy to snap on concepts
from Angular two or another framework.
As we go through this lesson.
I encourage you to work through
each of the steps yourself.
Build up the app along with me.
You'll learn a lot by watching me
work through building up a project.
But you'll learn so
much more if you build it yourself.
Angular is an awesome framework.
And when we're finished, I hope you'll
love working with it as much as I do.